hey guys welcome back to another brand
new video about the dev stream I do
apologize if my voice sounds a bit weird
I woke up maybe about 20 minutes before
the dev stream started so I'm very tired
so I do apologize for that in advance
but either way the videos still going up
we got a little bit of information some
future upcoming changes and stuff so
let's get right into this
so first up if you haven't heard yet for
Honor's gonna be releasing their first
ever double xp weekend that that'll be
going from August 25th to August 28th so
do it keep in mind about that maybe set
a few couple days of you know out of
your schedule and just go grind out for
some rap it is gonna be costing you know
it's double xp across all game modes all
orders stuff like that though BIV
there'll be a picture on screen for you
to see it is if it's not in your time
zone just kind of figure out when it is
either way it's gonna be all weekend so
hopefully you guys would enjoy that as
well and on top of that there's gonna be
a new community order called Dominion
Vanquisher where we need to complete as
many Dominion matches as possible and
get the 2000 steel you know just normal
stock we should probably be doing the
next and the first like day or two so
either way those are two things coming
this weekend next up if you didn't
notice there was an emergency patch
today but the patch did come with a bug
fixing the the message that says you
can't join the game because the session
is full so hopefully that works well
hopefully because I'm kind of sucky
seeing that it's like if it's full why
am I even being put in it either way
that's supposed to be fixing that issue
next week there's gonna be more balance
changes so stay tuned for those on the
characters regarding the duel tournament
the tournament will release this season
but there was a couple bugs that slipped
through the public tests so hopefully
that'll be released in the next update
they said but who knows when that'll be
next up Eric Pope went over a few bugs
people have discovered and that he's
been talking to on reddit but obviously
we can't read every reddit post so he
decided to talk about in the stream and
those bugs include the bug regarding
gladiators dodge which is still being
able to be tracked even though you're
dodging so certain attacks that you're
supposed to be dodging will even will
still even hit you so his his dodge is
broken the conquerer raw emote is being
fixed back to what it used to so all you
conquer means can rejoice now another
Dominion bug where your feet won't
unlock when it's supposed to is a bug as
well being fixed na and when a player
disconnects at the end of a Dominion
game it will restart at the beginning as
if you've never played them
I have I have not experienced any of
these bugs yet but that would be
horrible to witness so these are
definitely being patched and the bug
wear chip damages being is being able to
be killed there's being able to kill you
is also being fixed as well and the next
two things I have are not bugs but they
are ideas and one idea is that they're
going to have the add they're gonna add
the ability to have for executions at
once this won't be coming out this
season but they are definitely working
on it and then the next thing I have for
you is a video that shows a Highlander
alleging an opponent with this execution
and Ubisoft is saying they're gonna try
to add these into the game with all the
other types of its execution similar to
lawbreakers and this one as well so just
to give that a little immersion feel
because I guess a couple people are a
bit upset that these executions don't
ledge them when they clearly have the
potential to so they're gonna be working
on that next Thursday there's gonna be a
patch coming and to quickly summarize a
little bit of it it's mostly a bug-fix
patch and Highlanders GB range or Asgard
break range is being fixed to normal
like all the other normal characters
that was a huge problem if you've ever
played Highlander centurions faints and
attacks are gonna be costing a lot more
stamina there was a video posted a while
ago showing how many faints the
character can do before they run out of
stamina
I think Berserker can do about four and
Centurion can do about sixteen heavy
faints before he could do about sixteen
heavy faints before it allows him to
like run out of stamina so they're gonna
be reducing that to about eight
basically having that amount Raider
stampede charge startup is being
increased and being one of them being
the animation is also increased
basically meaning the animation has to
be up longer and you have to be
sprinting you can't just be running
around in a circle for a little bit for
the charge to work next up the conqueror
now will won't fall when being hit and
active hit and activating revenge this
was an unintended bug that only happened
to be used only happen to be affecting
the conker so that will be fixed as soon
as possible and the can say unlock tech
is also being fixed as well
Kenz I had a few bits of unlock tech
using a swift strike and that's gonna be
fixed as well other characters also have
unlock tech but and are being fixed but
they're not entirely done yet once again
this patch is going to be basically bug
fixes and it will be releasing next
Thursday at the time that the dev stream
goes alive next week that was basically
like I said like the video if you guys
did enjoy
subscribe if you're new and hit that
Bell right next to it see it every bus
one of my uploads hopefully you guys did
enjoy also if you haven't noticed some
other foreigner youtubers likes multi
Kenzo boughs Phoenix and rody Bros and
all the other kinds have been getting
early access gameplay for a game called
observer I didn't I was unlucky to be
one of the few youtubers that didn't get
the early access code but the game looks
beautiful and it's basically a
combination of Dark Souls but with
martial arts in it and I have a long
history with Dark Souls because I've
played basically just about every game I
haven't beat every game but I've been
super excited for another type of Dark
Souls game a little bit I do plan on
uploading these this game for some
videos so if you guys do enjoy that you
check out gameplay that's on youtube all
the time or there's probably going to be
these youtubers streaming it all day on
Twitch or on YouTube gaming definitely
check it out maybe it'll be worth it for
yourself the games coming out August
29th on Tuesday so hopefully you guys
will be interested in just as much as I
am I'm gonna be enjoying it hopefully
you guys will come along on the ride for
me and we can have two games to talk
about
yeah but either way newest videos
popping up on screen for you guys I'll
see you later guys peace out